but that's like the least inspiring
introduction that I've ever been given
it's like you know we've we've already
heard this same material from other
people but we haven't written kevins
boys so let's do it again actually I'm
really going to make an effort to tell
you things that you won't have heard
from the various other spectrum auction
talks even to the level of slides of my
own which are beloved by me which have
appeared in other talks I will leave out
from this particular one so so if you
don't know how spectrum auctions work
then bad news for you I'm not going to
tell you that much about the answer to
that question I'm really going to try to
focus on the computational stuff so lift
again and before we do let me point out
that this is joint work with a couple of
my students Alex flesh yet who has been
poached by Google and an eel moomin who
so far has not yet been poached by
Google and is here with us today so
thanks to both of them for their efforts
so the FCC is running a an incentive
auction it's the first auction ever to
feature incentives or something and
basically the idea this is to sell more
radio spectrum to telecom companies so
that they can you know make your phone
work better you'll get more bars on your
phone and download those videos you want
to download on your commute the problem
is they're you know just isn't any more
spectrum for them to sell and so you
know for a while they've just been
selling unused spectrum and it's been a
great thing they've been improving the
economy and reducing the national debt
and making everybody happier but at some
point you run out of different colors of
invisible light and you have to do
something else so what they're doing now
is repurposing spectrum that was
previously allocated to one purpose and
I'm moving it over to another purpose
and in particular in the early days of
radio spectrum some really prime
spectrum was given to broadcast TV
because that was almost the only thing
that spectrum was being used for at the
time and now it turns out that not very
many people watch TV that's broadcast
over the air and a lot of people would
like their mobile phones to work better
and so there's kind of an opportunity to
repurpose things so broadly speaking the
way the incentive auction is going to
work is that spectrum is going to be
bought back from from television
broadcasters who are going to be paid to
stop being broadcasters to go off the
air
and it's then going to be repackaged and
sold to and for other uses and most
likely and mobile phones so and this is
a big deal of course we don't know how
much money and auction is going to make
until the auction happens but
indications are that it's going to make
a lot of money so and the Congressional
Budget Office is the the branch of the
u.s. government whose job it is to make
impartial determinations of how much
things are going to cost the government
and their official ruling was that it
was going to net between add 10 and 40
billion dollars for the government and
that's that's NAT so the government has
to spend money to buy the buy out the TV
stations and then it's going to turn
around and repackage that spectrum and
sell it off and it's expected to be
making this kind of money from what I
understand from Paul more recently I
think I think that there are now some
indications the numbers might even be
getting bigger and based on some sort of
public estimates of the values of things
but but it's clear that this is a an
enormous application of auction theory
albeit one that's going to happen only
once in the US and it's coming up really
soon so and in the end of the first
quarter next year this is projected to
happen so mark your calendars for March
29th and you know be prepared to see a
real victory of algorithmic game theory
and practice and start to lift off so
I'm going to as I said say very little
about how the auction works so this is
my only slide really about how the
auction works which is intended to give
some scaffolding to those of you who
might not have heard the many spectrum
auction talks that have happened at
Simon's already and but broadly speaking
there going to be two different auctions
happening so there's going to be a so
called forward or ascending price
auction in which spectrum is being sold
off to people who want to buy more
spectrum probably telecoms and prices in
each region are going to be increasing
as long as demand exceeds supply and at
the same time there's going to be a
reverse or descending price option for
broadcasters in which broadcasters are
being offered money to buy out their
television stations and and free up this
spectrum that is ultimately getting sold
and
and essentially I'm going to speak only
about this reverse auction the for
reduction is pretty traditional at this
point this is similar to what's being
done in the past and there are a few
wrinkles for this new auction design in
the for reduction but first of all not
not any that I've been particularly
involved in and secondly and the the
real innovation has happened on the
reverse auction side I think it's fair
to say so so in this case you've got
kind of a funny thing or many of you
might be used to thinking about
combinatorial auctions when you think
about spectrum auctions here what's
combinatorial is the constraints whereas
the bidders a really simple we have
single minded bidders at least to a
first order approximation where every
bitter is a television station who is
trying to decide should I stop being a
television station or at least I stop
being a broadcast television station or
should I hold on to my station and so
they just have to make a yes or no
decision what's combinatorial is the
decision that the auctioneer is making
about which stations to buy out because
the auctioneer has a constraint that
across the whole country and wants to
clear a certain amount of spectrum and
in order to do that it doesn't want to
buy out too many stations in one market
and it certainly has to make sure it
doesn't bio to few stations in another
market so and that's that's where the
kind of combinatorial optimization is
going to come in here and now in order
to ensure that this auction makes money
for the government rather than the
reverse we need to ensure that we don't
end up paying a lot to clear a lot of
spectrum and then not getting very much
money to sell it and so in order to
ensure this the two oxygens are linked
and I'm not going to say much about that
but there's a revenue target specified
and in legislation to say that the
auction has to cover it essentially
cover its costs and cover the the
retuning costs associated with moving
around the broadcaster's who don't get
bought out and and so basically if we
haven't yet achieved that amount of
revenue then we and the two auctions
have both stopped then what we can do is
just say you know we were wrong about
how much spectrum we were going to clear
we're originally running an auction
where we were trying to buy out you know
some some particular amount of spectrum
I some particular number of TV channels
let's just reduce that amount of
spectrum that we're trying to buy out
now this will
allow us to continue running both
auctions so then we'll have less demand
in the auction where we're buying and
more supply in the auction where we're
selling and and maybe the other way
around but anyway and we can keep
running things so we can ensure we have
positive revenue so here's the thing
that I am going to focus most of my time
on today this is the question of
feasibility testing which is kind of
inherent to the way that the auction
works so in this reverse auction what's
going on is you're a television station
and I'm going to come to you and say you
know my starting price for your
television station is 50 million dollars
would you like to relinquish your
broadcast rights in exchange for 50
million dollars and these numbers have
been chosen to be deliberately really
high so the hope is very many TV
stations are going to say that sounds
fantastic of course my broadcast rights
are worth 50 million dollars to me I can
keep you know serving most of my
customers on cable anyway and I'd be
happy to to sell to you and then we get
an initial situation where there are a
lot of broadcasters who have agreed to
go off the air and in fact there are
many more than we need to meet the
clearing target that we have which is
lucky because these prices are
astronomically high for the government
to be paying so then what happens is we
start seeing whether we actually need
each of the broadcasters and if we don't
need them which is to say everything
would be feasible if that broadcaster
wasn't to go off the air then we offer a
lower price to that broadcaster and we
keep kind of iterating round robin
through the broadcasters until
everything stabilized until basically we
need everybody or until people decide
that they don't like the prices they're
being offered and they decide to go back
on the air and they stop participating
in the auction so from this region point
of view this is great it's very simple
because bidders are making bit are being
made a series of take it or leave it
offers that are just descending in price
so it's easy to see the bidders have a
dominant strategy in this option and the
computational problem though is figuring
out whether we actually need the bidders
that's the part that I'm worried about
here so what this means is every single
time I want to go to any better and
there are
2991 stations so there are nearly 3,000
agents who might be participating in
this auction depending on who makes
these initial decisions to participate
they have to go to every one of them and
say would it be possible to not take
this station would it be possible for
this station who's currently told me
that he's willing to go off the air
would it be possible to put him back on
the air given the reduced number of
channels that I'm trying to make
everything fit into and asking that
question is more or less a graph
coloring problem it's not quite a graph
coloring problem because we have side
constraints so turns out the way that
radio propagation works if I'm on
channel 17 it might be that cost us who
broadcast near me also can't be on
channel 17 but it might be that he's so
close to me that he also can't be on
channel 18 so it's kind of adjacent
color constraints in the graph coloring
formulation and but but broadly speaking
is kind of a graph coloring problem and
that's bad news because even just as a
straight-up graph coloring problem it's
easy to see you know thats MP complete
so I in principle I'm going to have to
solve many many many of these problems
and in simulations it's on the order of
about a hundred thousand problems /
auction that need to be solved because
we're going to have to solve it once for
every guy in the option for every price
tag so every time I want to lower
somebody's price I have to ask this
question and and and and that problem is
enormous and not just in the number of
stations but also in the number of
constraints as sorry I'll just finish my
sentence so we have almost three million
interference constraints between all
these different stations the reason the
number is so high is that actually the
you know Costas and I might interfere on
channel 17 but oddly enough we might
actually not interfere on channel 26
because these are different frequencies
so the propagation characteristics are
actually different you know their signal
might be more absorbed by trees and one
frequency than another as I saw a couple
hands over here so the constraint the
coloring constraint is it that you just
have a number of colors is it just you
trying to clear the same frequencies
across the country or maybe I have these
frequencies in on the east coast these
different frequency than the west coast
is it combinatorial erza just an
of colors and the number of the codes
that had sounds common tutorial to me so
I'm not sure what the distinction is
theorized canyon 3 kind of throughout
the graph or is it I'm more or less I
mean there are the various places where
something might be held out for some
kind of complicated reason I mean
anytime you dig into something practical
there's sort of irritating complexity
that the creeps end because of all sorts
of special cases so but but sort of to a
first order approximation that yes we're
going to say I want to take all of the
TV channels which are now in between I
think it's 14 252 and I want to change
that so it's 14 229 and so everybody
who's in any of those higher channels
that have to get moved down which is
fine I don't care where they go but but
you know I'm gonna have everybody who's
willing to participate in the auction
off the air I'm going to have some
people who weren't willing to be in the
auction all on the air and I'm already
having to repack them i'm having to
assign them different channels than they
used to have because i've gotten rid of
some of their channels and then when I
going round robin trying to decide
whether people's prices can lower I have
to ask and you know is it possible to I
have this problem that's solvable for
all the people who are currently on the
air is it also solvable when i add you
and I have to ask that for everybody
yeah I think he said that you you do
this unilateral test if I drop this
station I'm I still able to me my spy
constrain why is it unilateral ruffle in
a sense of stations that could all be
simultaneously drums um well because we
can make these price decrements one at a
time so I wanted they say synchronously
all because you can sort of see even
think of one kind of round of price
lower rings as just you know one pass
round robin for all the stations but the
order does matter because if i go to you
first and you say i'm not going to
accept your price i'm going back on the
air that might change you know whether
it was possible to deal with Shannon or
not yeah
so off that is reused yes and so so
actually Congress had to pass
legislation to make this auction
possible to happen for among other
things that reason so stations who want
nothing to do with this auction you
don't have to give up their TV station
but they're not guaranteed that they're
going to end up on the frequency that
there are now so what they are
guaranteed is that they're going to end
up on a frequency that doesn't have
significant interference with other
stations and so that's that's what all
these constraints are there ensuring
that everybody who's on the air is in
you know decent place where they can
reach the people that they're reaching
now okay so so initially when i first
got involved in this project some
skepticism was expressed to me about
whether this problem could be attacked
at the national scale and your people
were thinking about things like what if
we just you look at some sub area what
if we'd or what i'm trying to think
about a given station i look at some
geographic radius around that station to
try to make the problem smaller and even
then it was a pretty challenging problem
and that really doesn't work very well
and i think if you look at the the graph
of the united states with the true
constraints drawn on here even though
it's a bit small you can see why that is
it's just really densely connected
particularly around here and so just the
constraints can propagate pretty far and
so making some kind of artificial
restriction is just going to be cutting
a lot of edges for no reason you're
going to take a lot of problems that
might be feasible and making them beyond
infeasible something i should say that's
really important is given that this you
know i'm trying to solve an np-complete
problem here you might wonder what
happens if you just fail to solve it you
know okay Leighton Brian you can make
your fancy fast AI algorithms but you're
not going to change the laws of math and
so you know sometimes you're just not
going to succeed in solving something so
something I think that's really cool
about this auction design is that it's
kind of robust to occasional failures so
what happens is and every time we want
to lower a price for somebody we can
only do that when we can prove that it's
possible to put that person back on the
air if they want to leave if in the
amount of time we have we're just unable
to
prove that then we just have to act as
though we've proven that it's not
possible to put that person on the air
which means their price has to just
freeze for all time at that level and
that's costly for us but it's not a
complete disaster it only effects that
one bitter and the rest of the option
can proceed as it does and so what that
means is if once in a while were unable
to solve problems that's going to have a
kind of direct financial cost I don't
think I know an example of solving
combinatorial optimization algorithms
using heuristics where there's as
director relationship between
incremental e solving a few more
problems and making huge amounts of
money but but nevertheless it sort of
degrades very gradually with the number
of problems that we can't solve yeah big
lorry splat price you cannot if IQ but
you can also not prove that he's not
remarkable exactly this other guy for UT
park or whatever then do you ever
consider going back to do is organize
case thanks the skin no for incentive
reasons right we don't want to give
people complicated incentive reasons
where they might try to affect the
hardness of the instance through
something and basically if you if I ever
make you an offer where when I say okay
your price is frozen then if I want this
thing to be a simple and strategy proved
I just leave it to solve it not commit
that you are done so like that there is
some room they don't know the order in
which Europe so this is a more more
sophisticated question and various
designs of this form have been mooted I
think I'm not actually sure what what
situation we're in relative to these
rules i think the the official party
line right now is what I've told you
yeah as you see back in the day is to be
very worried about little like seemingly
little things like tiebreaking and kind
of the vagrancy zuv the way you do your
computation affecting the outcome of the
auction what are the how comfortable the
policymakers
with what you just said that the the
price dynamic somehow depends on the
ability to solve the computational
problem I would be a fool if I tried to
answer a question about how comfortable
the policymakers felt about anything and
so I won't I mean there's been a lot of
discussion about all sorts of very fine
details of this auction as there should
be because as all of you know from the
practical you know high stakes auctions
that have been held in the world
sometimes you know getting some small
detail wrong can matter a whole lot and
so I think there's been a lot of care
given to those sorts of things i think
the the policymakers have expressed kind
of you know competing interests they
they want to save as much money for the
government as they can they want to be
transparent and understandable to
bidders they want to have this thing
happen on schedule so i think they're
they're weighing all these sorts of
concerns anyone else all right yeah how
much time you have the song if you say
very tiny moment that's that's a
question interactive discussion and
consideration I hear Paul Milgram
laughing because he knows how much time
I spent thinking about this question but
on the order of a minute let's say I
mean if if we did fancy things like cost
us is proposing then maybe maybe longer
in the bad case instances but if we if
we do what I've been saying now then
something like a minute is waiting in
the station exit is waiting there for
you to let them know in a minute I think
we would only do like a couple rounds of
the auction per day so there's only
going to be you know on the order of a
couple of price movements per day so
this not besok shin is not like an
auction for a Picasso at Christie's that
everybody gets to go home in the evening
and someone's got the painting is this
is going to unfold over a long period of
time you've done this month problem and
you find out that you give it all for
this station a lower price and then but
you can't move on to the next station
till you know what the station did right
right so I think we we have basically
conditional information from assertions
about how they would respond to the one
movement if it were to come okay so um
so anyhow and my my punchline here as
you've been able to read in the last
like five or ten minutes on
slide is that you were indeed able to
solve these problems or else I wouldn't
be here telling you about it I think
part of the point of this talk is just
to tell you about that you're not the
inner workings of all these methods I
don't have time for that but the kinds
of methods that we use and the fact that
they work because I think that this sort
of broad program for how to attack a
hard computational problem about which
we know a lot in advance distribution
alee is one that is pretty broadly
applicable outside this area yeah so
much distributional e-letter you think
we're distributional information from
well for one thing I know that we don't
have to run this auction in China right
I know you know where all of the
television stations are in the United
States that's huge right I know this
master constraint graph that everything
is generated from secondly I know the
population distribution in the United
States and I know that the value of a TV
station has a lot to do with the
population that it serves I know the
signal strength of every TV station in
the United States and so along with the
population and some geographical
characteristics you know I can know
something to a first order about
valuations that tells me something about
what would happen in an auction I don't
want to believe that too firmly but you
know I can put some pretty big error
bars on that and end up with a
distribution okay so let me start
telling you some actual answers from
data so for the first I'll tell you two
different sets of data and this talk the
first one is a set of data that the FCC
I told me we're allowed to publicly
release and I think we'll be releasing
soon which is at this point very out of
date it's what the interference data is
already public the set of constraints
which is based on a clearing target of
trying to get everybody into 19 UHF
channels and and the data van student
can be able to release is this results
of some simulations which are based on
the smooth ladder auction mechanism and
valuation assumptions kind of along the
lines that I was explaining to Eva and
turns out there's some complexity about
if you're really old and you've ever
watched broadcast TV you might know that
there's this one thing called UHF and
this other thing called VHF there aren't
very many VHF channels and so the
repacking problem and VHF is pretty easy
so for this entire talk i'm just going
to focus only on UHF problems which are
much harder
mutational II and and we did a sort of
appropriate test training methodology
here we took all these problems we
randomly pulled out 10,000 test
instances and 1,000 validation instances
and we left everything else to train on
you'll understand better what i mean by
training as i know on and as i was
saying to ashish we have a one-minute
cut off so when i first got involved in
this problem there are a bunch of our
people already working on it and being
our people they and they like using
mixed integer programming solvers so
that's what they were using they'd
actually thought quite a lot about
generating fancy kinds of constraints
and I'm doing some relatively
sophisticated things which I actually
don't have their code and I'm not really
at liberty to try to recreate it and so
what I've done here is maybe a little
bit less good than what they did but I
think it's not really that different
what I've done here is just take off the
shelf suplex and goro B which are the
two kind of high-end and mixed integer
programming solvers and and I'm trying
to solve them on our distribution so let
me walk you through with this graph
means because you're going to see a lot
of graphs that look like this so on the
x-axis here I have run time said and
it's on a log scale so you know this is
a tenth of a second and this is a second
and this is 60 seconds which is my
cutoff time and on the y-axis I have the
fraction of instances that I've solved
within that amount of time so for
example you can see that within one
second cplex which is the blue line is
sold a little bit more than ten percent
of the instances in our test set and by
the end cplex has rallied and managed to
self about half of the instances there's
guru B's doing a bit less well so this
is pretty terrible right you would
really hate to run an auction with a one
minute cut off using these solvers
because you know half of the time this
isn't even half the stations but half
the time you ask the question you're
going to end up saying sorry I'm not
able to tell whether that price can be
lowered I'm going to have to not lower
it people are going to end up on average
with prices pretty close to the starting
points which are high on purpose so that
they encourage participation and the
government is going to be believing
money and it would be a disaster so so
that's why people were thinking that
doing this at a national scale didn't
seem like a good idea
this is on a high-end cluster computer I
mean I'm running on one core these are
these are all single core algorithms but
this is on a classroom at ubc mystical
for like I don't know like 10 minutes
would I get ninety percent yeah well I
mean you can kind of see like it you
know these curves tend to sort of
flapping rather than suddenly becoming
spectacular it's on a log scale you can
sort of extrapolate in your head and see
that within any kind of reasonable
amount of time that would be consistent
with running a couple auction rounds a
day you know you're not going to
suddenly be getting that you present and
even ninety percent is it's not you know
all that could be wished for and so the
first thing that struck me when I got
involved in this is that it's a bit of a
funny choice to be using mixed integer
programming to try to solve this problem
because there's nothing being maximized
here there are no real values in the
constraints it's a really a purely
combinatorial decision problem and as a
person in a I if I think about a purely
combinatorial decision problem the most
obvious thing to think about is a
reduction to sat so that's what we did I
won't walk you through the reduction but
this is all very straightforward and
what I will point out most of all is
that the the reduction produces mostly
clauses of length 2 if you just kind of
skim through these constraints that I've
drawn here you'll notice that most of
the constraints are pairs of
disjunctions and only one of them is a
disjunction of many variables and that's
a good thing for sat solvers in practice
because I'm sure you all know that two
SAT is easily solvable in polynomial
time and in practice if I have a clause
that is mostly two clauses I can a more
or less search over the non to Clause
part and then sort of propagate
constraints through the two clauses and
solve things pretty quickly so what
actual sophisticated solvers do is a
little bit more complicated than that
but it's a good intuition to have that
the two clauses are kind of a good case
for sat solvers and so every year
there's a SAP competition where the sock
community makes their best SAT solvers
and and puts them all head-to-head
there's been amazing progress in the
side community over the last few decades
in incrementally improving these solvers
and I'm not only are they doing a great
job of making their solvers faster but
they're also making the public
available through these competitions so
it becomes possible to download a bunch
of solvers and try them all and we tried
a large number of solvers I think made
like a couple of dozen solvers and the
ones that I'm graphing here are just the
best ones to avoid giving you a really
cluttered graph and but what we found is
that they pretty much dominate the mixed
integer programming solvers for this
problem it really seemed to be a good
idea to work with SAT solvers the best
SAT solver that we had is at DC CA which
is actually a local search algorithm so
it's not able to prove unsatd all but it
turned out most of the problems in our
test set our satisfiable so that was
okay and and you know that even the
worst one here is an algorithm called
clasp is doing about as well as our best
mixed integer programming solver and
lies above it most of the time so on the
whole SAT really seem to be doing pretty
well but even so we're getting you know
less than three quarters of the problem
solved in a minute using our best
algorithm that's still a lot less than
we want in practice oh and here's a I'm
puttin underneath these cumulative
density functions a histogram of
satisfiability status showing you
whether the problems being solved for
satisfiable or unsatisfiable so so in
this histogram I have a blue area if the
problem was SAT a red area if the
problem was unsat and a grey area if it
times out so of course all the time outs
are over here you might be forgiven if
you think that there isn't any red
anywhere in fact there is it's always at
the top so you can see some little
regions of red but there's really not
very much it's kind of a side effect of
the way the auction works because once I
encounter an unsatisfiable problem that
station gets frozen and I stopped seeing
problems that have that station in it
and so I tend to spend most of my time
in the course of an actual auction
generating satisfiable problems so
that's kind of good news in particular
for things like dcca that are
satisfiable and generally in practice
it's faster to prove satisfiability than
to prove unsatisfiable ax t because you
get to stop when you encounter a
solution and on the other hand it's sort
of discouraging because that means we
might expect that a lot of this region
is also satisfiable which means that's
money left on the table so what do we do
to make things better
turns out a topic near and dear to my
heart that my research group has been
focusing on for more than a decade now
something we call algorithm
configuration and the idea is to think
about the design of heuristic algorithms
not as a process of human ingenuity and
exploration but instead as a process of
combinatorial search really in the end
you have these various different design
decisions you could make in in designing
a heuristic algorithm and what we
usually do the kind of canonical
approach is that you have some intuition
about what would work well and you run
some experiments and you see how it does
and then you look at those experiments
and you think maybe I should have
changed something and you change that
thing and you run another experiment and
you could have iterate a few times until
you get to the paper deadline and then
you you send that to triple-a the
problem with that is that that's a
pretty lousy search algorithm right I'm
doing kind of coordinate descent I'm
changing only one thing at a time it's
very likely that these heuristics impact
on performance is correlated it's likely
that my starting point is not the best
place to start and and I'm in this high
dimensional combinatorial space so it's
really likely that there's just great
stuff there that I never find so what
we've been working on is the design of
algorithm configurators which are meta
algorithms in the sense of their
algorithms that take other algorithms as
part of their input so you give me a set
of problems that you want good
performance on a way of measuring
performance and an algorithm which has
many parameters and these parameters can
be absolutely anything it's a black box
so you can use these parameters just to
express all of the different heuristic
ideas that you might have had and then
you kind of throw this thing on a
computer cluster and wait for a few days
and it does this Explorer exploration
for you so it basically draws on the
statistics literature and experiment
design and black box function
optimization does some kind of clever
machine learning on the inside and in
the end comes back with a configuration
that it can show to statistical
significance performs better than
anything else that it can find and so we
and it seems like a really good target
application for algorithm configuration
here because as I was saying to evo we
know that we're facing the u.s.
constraint graph we know
you know a lot about the kinds of
stations that we're facing and so we
really are happy to build something that
kind of narrows in just on that part of
the problem we want to be careful that
we don't over fit our training data
that's why we do this training test
split so that we're sure that we do
generalize within our distribution
otherwise though this seems like a good
thing to do and in particular we used an
algorithm that we call sequential model
based algorithm configuration or smack
and the way that this works is that we
build a response function in parameter
space so you can kind of imagine a space
that has one dimension for every
parameter and one more dimension a
response to mention for a runtime and
you can kind of picture in your head
that there's some true underlying
response surface that says for every
parameter what's my average run time in
this distribution for that joint
parameter setting and then what we do is
we use a random fourths of regression
trees which we've already heard a little
bit about at this conference and to
build this response surface in real time
based on some initial exploration we
find a place that looks good in terms of
that response surface and then we go
actually find out whether it is good we
conduct an experiment which means we run
the algorithm actually on those problems
we see how they do and if they look good
then great but even if they look bad
that allows us to to learn more about
our response surface and we just keep
iterating until we run out of time
basically and so so that's what we did
I'm happy to talk more about this if
anyone's interested in it and but the
upshot is that we built a new solver
called clasp h2 for reasons that I won't
tell you but but we built this new
solver which is just clasp but with
different parameter settings so
something I didn't tell you before is
that clasp is actually an algorithm that
was made by its creators specifically to
work well in this paradigm of algorithm
configuration so they exposed many many
parameters that do all kinds of
different things and and they really
want to leave it up to people like me to
just find things that are going to work
well in their distribution and so this
algorithm which actually started out as
our worst algorithm you might remember
improve so much that it it's the green
line up here it becomes far better than
the best thing we had seen before and
we're now at the point of solving about
85
presented the problems and there's one
more thing that I might do I might ask
can the previous assignment be something
you might notice about the way the
auction works is I've always got a
previous assignment right I'm always
having a solvable problem and trying to
add one station to a solvable problem so
one thing you might ask is can I just
add the station without changing
anything it turns out the FCC software
already does that without even talking
to me and that solves eighty percent of
the problems so everything I'm talking
about here is something that they gave
me which means that didn't work but the
next best thing that I might do is say
can it be augmented by fixing every
station that doesn't neighbor the
station that I'm interested in to its
value in the previous solution and just
solving this the induced sub problem in
the immediate neighborhood of the the
station that I've got if I ended up
proving that that was unsatd just be
that I had to make bigger changes in the
graph as a whole but that might be a
really fast way of driving myself for as
a SAT solution and so we built sort of
pre solver that just tries this for a
short time and sees if it works and then
goes and tries to solve the real problem
and we put that together with this
configured version of clasp and we ended
up getting this performance that you see
here so here's here's the configured
clasp and here's configured class but
the pre solver and also some kind of
software engineering trickery to make
things faster and this was called a sad
FC feasibility checker based on
satisfiability 1 point 0 which was
released by the FCC last November so
about a year ago and so that's that that
was our kind of previous benchmark we we
got written up in the in the press that
cares about such things amazingly you
know TV technology com I'm sure you all
follow it but but if you don't and I i
was particularly happy here that he says
i doubt many individuals will have the
time or resources to generate their own
feasibility checks it sucks up computer
power so they're the people were
clamoring for us to make this faster
literally coming to my door okay not
literally and but but indeed we you know
we're still leaving a bunch of money on
the table so we really wanted to make
this thing faster and so we look for
some other things we could do to make to
leverage the specific problem one thing
we can do is take local
search solvers like dcca and actually
seed them with the the previous solution
rather than having them just work at
random that turns out to help a bed and
we've tried incidentally many things
that I'm not telling you about because
they didn't help all of these things did
help and another thing we can do is we
can take the induced constraint graph
from a given problem and try to
decompose it into a disconnected
components and if we find disconnected
components we can solve each of them
separately and for example if I was to
find that one component was unsat then
it doesn't matter if I can't even solve
some other component I've already shown
that the whole problem is unset and one
more thing that I can do is I can say is
there a station which is unconstrained
in the sense that for every assignment
of the other stations it's always the
case that this station can take some
feasible value may be a different
feasible value in every case if I can
prove that this fact is true about some
station then I can just omit this
station from the problem because I know
that I could repair any solution that I
found to fix this station and it turns
out this can actually really help
furthermore if I do this first I can end
up getting more graph decomposition than
if I if I didn't do this because it
involves dropping some station so I end
up disconnecting my graph a bit and so
looking at how much under constraint
station solving helps and here's a CDF
showing the degree of stations that we
find in the real problems that we
encounter so we're seeing problems with
up to and station degrees of 60 so
stations that interfere with 60 other
stations that are really already on the
air and and and here I'm saying and how
often was I able to detect and remove a
station as being under constrained and
we had an initial heuristic that we used
and then we ended up finding something
fancier and better so the initial
heuristic that we used is able to get up
to about eight percent and you see that
it sort of tops out at stations with
very low degree we ended up with
something much faster faster based on
our consistency that gets us up above
forty five percent the reason I'm
telling you about both of them is that
the results i'm showing you right now
are based on this green line and the
results that all kind of just ran at the
end are based on the red line
and the next thing that we did was to
build algorithm portfolios so you know
just as a financial portfolio works by
saying let me exploit variants in the
performance of different stocks by
owning many stocks we can do the same
thing with algorithms for solving hard
computational problems so it turns out
that they tend to have very high
variance in their run times and that
these variances are often uncorrelated
and so it can be a really good strategy
not to run one algorithm but to run many
even if you had to task swap them on the
same process or even if you're you're
not getting parallel computation for
free you can really gain something by
running many things at the same time and
again this is something my group has
been working on for a long time we
developed something called sad zilla
which is pictorially described in this
this image here and it's been winning a
lot of SAT competitions over the last
kind of decade or so just basically by
taking other people's SAT solvers which
I don't really understand and putting
them together with machine learning and
making them outperform their constituent
parts oh really shows the power of this
kind of machine learning approach in
combinatorial optimization another thing
that we can do and that we've proposed a
bit more recently is something we call
Hydra which basically says what if I
start with one highly parametrized
solver and I want to build a portfolio
out of it so I want to end up with a
bunch of uncorrelated solvers that can
be put together that perform well
together but my starting point is just
this space that you have to search you
have to make these things yourself so
hydras and methodology for doing that
and that's actually what we did in the
FCC problem so we actually ran Hydra
many times both kind of configuring our
existing solvers and choosing among them
to eventually find a set of things that
worked well together and I'm happy to
tell you offline how Hydra works but the
upshot is we made a 4 algorithm
portfolio and it and so we were going to
run SATA see actually runs on 4
processors at the same time and it looks
like this so we actually ended up we
looked at you know a couple dozen SAT
solvers but amazingly we ended up
choosing to clasp variants even though
they're so similar so clasp really was
powerful for our problem and and we
ended up choosing a version of GCC a
that augments based on the previous
solution and we ended up
building a pre solver based on DC CA and
if you put all of these things together
and run them in parallel then and then
we look at which things solves first
then I get the performance of this
maroon line which is starting to look
pretty good here and now getting pretty
close to a hundred percent of the
problem solved something like 98 the set
of instances you looking at are you
simulate running the option like you
simulate several options and for each
option you get a lot of subproblems yes
it so just to be clear I then take that
set of problems I separate them into two
sets I do my algorithm configuration on
a training set and I evaluate the
results on a held out test set and what
you're seeing in every picture I show
you is test set results yeah it's held
out from ocean assist the instance not
from rounds around so this is held out
just from instance to instance because
the data set that I'm telling you about
doesn't identify the option that things
came from and at the very end of the
talk I'll show you some results that are
held out auction by auction which is it
obviously more interesting um okay so
the last idea we have that I'm gonna
have to go through very quickly which is
a shame because I think it's a really
cool idea is caching so it turns out
that you know I really would be willing
to leverage a huge amount of offline
time if I could make my solver faster I
know the constraint graph in advance I
know so i have this distributional
information you know if I could somehow
use this to you know run on a cluster
forever and ever I could save billions
of dollars for the government it seems
like a good idea the problem is I can't
just solve every problem offline because
there are 2 to the N possible problems
and n here is 3,000 and so I can't
generate every possible problem even in
the u.s. constraint graph and of course
all these three thousand problems don't
occur in practice and because of what i
said about populations and how that
affect valuation and all of that and the
way the auction rules actually work and
so i might hope that there's more
structure to what happens really in
practice so maybe i should build a cache
and just remember what I've actually
seen in practice and see if I ever
encounter it again in a different
auction and does that work no basically
I never see the same thing again almost
never and so we rebuilt a cash on a
training set of 200,000
we evaluate on a test this test that i
told you about of 10,000 problems we
were just never seeing the same thing
again so this idea was just not working
um but here's the the inside that made
things work and if a station said it's
reap a cabal then every superset of that
station set is also reap a keable right
if I can solve a given problem then you
know I could drop some parts of that
solution and I would always still have a
valid solution so um this is good
because they're exponentially many super
sets of a given set so this dramatically
increases my chance of getting a
collision in my cash and so you might
think I should you know go to my cash
and query to say is there some super set
I've ever seen before and you know use
that as my cash that's great the problem
is I need to find a way of querying this
cash because there are now an
exponential number of different keys
that I want to be able to hit with a
given query so I need to find some
querying algorithm that runs in real
time where I can say you know here's my
query string do you have some super set
of this canary strain in the database
and basically we found a way of doing
this will be built a traditional cash
that we can hash into and a secondary
cash that basically allows us to map
queries and they and the original
queries into queries that are actually
going to hit something and I can't tell
you exactly how it works I think in the
time that I've got but it's it's kind of
a cool randomized algorithm that that
basically works by randomly ordering and
the different items in my secondary cash
based on their sort of bit string
representation under a random ordering
of the bets doing binary search and then
using the property that a superset is
going to be ordered higher in the list
and if I have many different lists all
according to different random orderings
then I hope that this prefix is going to
be short at least one of those lists and
I'm going to find the thing I'm looking
for quickly if that was too quick for
you I'm happy to talk about this part
offline and but instead let me tell you
how the cash actually did so on this
original set of problems the cash did
spectacularly well the cash is the
dashed line here I'm just putting it up
against the portfolio i showed you
before and this graph is saying how did
the cash actually work and it's saying
there's a lot of stuff that you know I
never hit in the cat
ever there's a lot of stuff that I hit
only one time some of it saves me almost
no time and some of it saves me enormous
amounts of time and then there
interestingly there are also keys that I
just hit over and over again and again
some of them saved me very little time
and some of them saved me a lot of time
so it seems like the cash and the cat
really was working for us in the end
we're solving 99% of the problems in a
fifth of a second and ninety nine point
six percent in 60 seconds so we were
pretty happy with these results and the
main thing that we and we released all
of this as SAT FC 2 point 0 and the main
thing that we were concerned about with
all this is this is all about one data
set and so the last thing that I want to
tell you about I just want to put up
some graphs that are really hot off the
press as of late last night of a much
newer simulation results so and the FCC
has been generating data in the last
couple of weeks so we have data that was
generated on auction simulations between
october twenty second and november six
so really recently and they generated
1.1 million instances in total and all
of these are instances that were not
directly solvable by augmenting the
previous solution and this comes from 80
auctions and all of these auctions are
based on different simulation
assumptions and the FCC didn't do this
to make a data set for me they did it
because they want to test the effect of
all kinds of crazy things that might
happen in the auction so these are
really a wide range of different kinds
of assumptions including assumptions of
evaluations who decides to participate
how much spectrum lee try to clear and
how long we runs out of c-4 and how that
affects the progress of the auction so
taking all of this stuff and kind of
throwing it together here's how at FC
does so here I'm showing you 80
different CDF's on the same graph and
I've drawn dark the median CDF median by
it said the point that it hits at the
end here so you can see that you know
overall we're doing very well and are
again I'll say we see the same pattern
we saw before of mostly satisfiable
problems and if i look at this solved
percentage and i should say all of these
experiments were done with the cash
turned off because that complicates the
analysis so that the true performance
would be better if we had the cash run
and but it's complicated except to think
about what we were trained it on and if
i look at the salt percentages here
drawn it's a histogram you can see that
most of the time we're solving you know
more than sort of mid to high nineties
percents of of instances there are a
couple of outliers that catch your eye
and the other one we were solving very
few luckily those are really
pathological cases that where the FCC
was trying things that they really don't
expect would happen we haven't retrained
on all this data yet we intend to you
know rerun algorithm configuration based
on all this data we imagine again that
would only improve performance this is
trained only on the previous data set
that I showed you and the last thing I
want to show you is we tried to test how
the cash works and what's tricky here is
that the FCC was not trying to make
things easy for me so they often reran
more or less the same auction with some
very small change in it and what I
wanted to do is what David was kind of
asking me about before some kind of
leave one out analysis where I leave out
a complete auction I train the cash on
everything else and then I see how well
the cash is doing on that auction and I
kind of try that everywhere said across
validate the problem is that that gets
complicated by the fact that two options
are more or less the same auction I end
up sort of training on my test data
testing on my training data and so what
we did here is an analysis where we took
every auction and we we looked at how
similar they were in the sense of how
many problems do they share in common
what fraction of the problems today
share and comment so I'm density on this
and heat map is by what fraction they
share in common from zero percent to one
hundred percent and we put a threshold
at twenty percent so we're coloring it's
the same luminance but the hue is red
when it's above twenty percent in its
blue when it's below so Neil and I
decided the twenty percent was a good
threshold for saying anything that's
above twenty percent is is too similar
we're going to call it the same auction
and anything that is below that we think
it's different enough we're going to
call it a different option so and under
that and similarity measure here's how
the cash does so so what I'm looking at
here is for each of the 80 options I
built a new cache containing all of
those auctions that weren't overly
similar to it which of course sort of
biases away from what the cash is good
at and trying to get problems that
whether it be a few direct cash
and and then and see how well I do in
this subset superset queries and and
what you see is again there are a few
pathological outlying cases where the
simulation assumptions were really
different from everything else and we do
very badly and most of the time we're
not doing quite as well as we were
before in that previous case which
doesn't surprise me because we weren't
doing a leave-one-out auction analysis
but our hit rate is still really high so
our median head rate is over here it's
about forty percent so something like
forty percent of the problems that we
encounter are solvable just by looking
at problems that we've solved before and
of course we can make this better and
better by just having a bigger and
bigger cash so we're obviously not going
to stop here we're going to you do as
much cash training as we can before the
auction really happens to try to push
this curve up and so I'll conclude there
thank you for your attention and happy
to take questions so the real action
that the real axis it will be
how do you know that there's no bugs in
the code you write the code baby right
if your call are they trusting your girl
there are you trusting their color as
you can imagine i've been asked this
question before they're you know they're
doing many things to worry about this i
mean one thing that were helped by the
fact that these problems are in NP
because if i claim that a problem is
unsolvable there's no calamity that
happens if i'm wrong right claiming that
a problem is unsolvable wrongly is like
timing out on a problem it's exactly
like it and so that would be a shame and
you know we don't think that we have
those kinds of bugs but if we did have
those kinds of bugs it's not terrible if
we encounter a case where I claim that a
problem is satisfiable and I'm wrong
that would be really terrible because I
could get the auction into a trajectory
where I can no longer repack everybody
and just awful things would happen and
people would come kill me in my sleep so
but luckily we just had you know three
independent teams right different code
that is in the critical path that checks
a claim of satisfiability and make sure
that it really is that it's viable
because why not it's really fast to do
so that that we really do do for
robustness and then of course they just
do all of this kind of enterprise
software validation to protect it from
everything the US government is
concerned about as you might imagine
after Obamacare software quality has
become a primary concern of the US
government so I think they're they're
doing a pretty good job was just making
sure that everything works the answer is
that you were out the software that they
go on to man yes you're gonna run our
software here okay and thanks very much